the title of my talk is the web
experience in the autistic spectrum
and i'd like to take this opportunity to
familiarize you with
the cognitive issues that some of your
users might be having while visiting
your site
or using your application
from the perspective of the autistic
spectrum and in particular the
asperger's syndrome which i'll be
focusing on
understanding and
catering for the needs of such users may
be beneficial not only for
you and for your product
but also
for the target
audience in its entirety
so
regardless of whether you're a developer
or a designer
designing with uh cognitive
accessibility in mind um
will
will generate a pretty widespread uh
payoff which i hope will be quite
impressive but more on that uh in a bit
um
so my name is natalia berdis i've come
from krakow poland as jetset
i've recently quit my office job to
start a new career as an ios developer
and yay and
uh you might be wondering why uh
why i've chosen such a topic for a
presentation at jsconf and what my
credentials are
uh well the thing is that this talk is
very personal for me since um i've i've
been diagnosed with asperger's syndrome
when i was a child and
my talk will be based largely on my
personal observations
as well as on the research i've done
online and
on interviews that i've conducted with
fellow aspies online as well
um
first of all let me briefly explain what
what autism is in fact it is not a black
or white condition
it is an entire range of conditions that
comes in many different shades and
flavors
so this ranges from
severe autism and can autism
these guys are usually non-communicative
at all they have a severe learning
disability
and
the distractions that they experience
are mostly physical
and
at the upper end of the spectrum we have
high functioning autism and asperger's
syndrome these two terms
are now increasingly being used
interchangeably and
these guys have
relatively normal language acquisition
um an extreme some extreme abilities
relatively high iq and the distractions
that they experience
are mostly mental and cognitive
and i'm sure
that many of you
here perhaps have asperger's
and you definitely know someone who does
it's just that they may not have been
diagnosed yet they may just appear to be
super geeky
and i'm sure you know people such as
thomas jefferson or
isaac newton
or richard stallman of the free software
foundation fame or even bill gates
now these people have never been
officially diagnosed but
trust me
us aspies do
sense certain kinship with them so um my
bet is that they probably have
asperger's too
um i would even go one step further uh
half the silicon valley probably has has
aspergers
and
like i said they they are
the geeky types that tend to flock
together a lot but more on that in a bit
um
as i've said i'll be focusing on
asperger's syndrome
uh so
what is it in general
in fact people with asperger's syndrome
they're just really
quite normal to be honest they might
appear just a bit weird and just a bit
eccentric
and depending on on the situation they
might appear to have a very
low
intelligence
especially if it's a social situation or
a higher iq
especially when they're online or alone
now um
people with asperger's differ from
the so-called neurotypical people
in four fields in general social skills
language interests and perception so i'd
like to just briefly uh sketch the type
of user that we're dealing with here
and
after i've done that i will explain what
you can do as developers and designers
to
provide a sense of relief
to the issues that they might be facing
uh first of all when it comes to social
skills people with asperger's
uh
have a have what's called mind blindness
um which entails a certain difficulty in
guessing other people's thoughts and
feelings
it boils down to me thinking that there
is no
such thing as an autonomous mind of
yours
so if i think something my first
instinct is that you think precisely the
same and it really requires a lot of
extra attention to
to to find out that that's not the case
um
then there's
then what stems from the above is a
certain lack of empathy
so people with asperger's might appear a
bit detached
there are issues with non-verbal
communication so
if you are wearing a paper bag over your
head and talking to me it would really
make no difference at all because
aspies usually don't really read well
into all these facial twitches that you
use to express something
and when it comes to social situations
there is a certain sense of rigidity too
um
it's it's very hard to play all the
social games and um participate in the
social status quo so imagine um it's
like putting a computer out in a social
context
and sending a computer to a post office
to fill out a form
if there are certain rules to be
followed and they're very specific
then
it's doable but as soon as some kind of
adaptability and improvisation is
required
uh then it becomes really difficult so
the way we usually cope with that is we
feel like being in an rpg game or an
actor in a play which is what i'm doing
right now so
that makes social context easy
when it comes to language
language itself is not really affected
but
what is the fact it is the way it is
used and interpreted it
language
verbal communication is something really
fairly artificial and painful that
really clouds the um
thought imagery a lot
um
then there are also issues when it comes
to um
interpreting irony metaphors jokes
and double entenders
aspies are known to interpret everything
directly and literally and they really
can't take a joke
their speech is very idiosyncratic they
love talking about a very specific
subject
it's especially visible in little
children that sound very academic almost
like little professors
so it's really pedantic and
expressionistic and spiked with sensory
vocabulary
when it comes to learning
people with high functioning autism and
asperger's
are mostly not all of them but they're
mostly very visual thinkers so they
store catalogues of of images rather
than very abstract ideas or abstract
thoughts
um
furthermore
their interests
are
they boil down to collecting things
memorizing things they have very narrow
and specialist minds when i was a young
girl of
four or five
what i would do
for days on end was memorizing the
population of countries
and the lengths of their coastlines and
their areas and their gross national
income etc
and we're also very detail-obsessed
details always come first and that is
the most important thing
um
then there's perception obviously the
sensitivity is fairly unusual
it can be either heightened or lowered
and
that applies to both
uh
to to everything such as textures or and
food and fabric and colors
and temperature or pain
then there's also uh the perception of
imagery and audio uh obviously
fluorescent lights and
obnoxious sounds are bothersome but
what's really terrible is when a sound
comes from many different sources at the
same time so that can really lead to a
and
perceptive perceptive overload
um and we're also very pattern oriented
so
when i see a pattern it can either be
very eye-catching and fascinating or
very confusing
but that might also come in handy
because
i can spot a deviation from a pattern
very easily so for example if i'm in a
library and someone tells me that
they've misplaced a book somewhere
i can like
scan through the 20 shelves very very
quickly and spot it in under 10 seconds
and shopping in a supermarket is also
easy thanks to that
so
now this all begs the question how to
make the web a friendly place for people
with such
cognitive challenges
first of all i'd like to state that
us aspies we have very technical
interests
and we absolutely love and adore
computers because computers give us
control
computers are structured they allow for
categorization
and we can find very specific
information
we can store it and process it
and we can program the machines so that
they um
so that they listen to our strictly
defined rules
asperger's syndrome like i said is often
called the geek syndrome for a reason
obviously
and
for us the computer and the internet is
our best friend and the web is
our primary portal
to the world
so
i would like to emphasize that
um
what you might consider to be best
practice or common sense in development
or design
becomes an absolute necessity for
someone uh with cognitive issues to
actually function on the web
and um
by catering for that you actually can
allow those people to
to perform social functions that
they wouldn't be able to do otherwise
first of all
every single site or every single app
has a certain structure
now people with asperger's they usually
take
they have bottom-up minds so they
usually take details
and they put them
into their own structures
now a website or an app
already has a structure that you impose
upon your user so you have to make
absolutely sure
that the structure that you impose is
logically correct because if there's
something
shady about it logically speaking
then we just go
instantly and just shut the thing down
if something doesn't match so
how do you go around this
the first thing that you can do is to
provide ways to bypass the imposed
structure
obviously a site map is
one of such ways
and this pertains not only to people
with cognitive disabilities but
but with
any other disabilities that you might
think of
this i mean site map is usually the very
first place that they look
um another um
another way to bypass the structure
obviously is to implement some sort of
search functionality
um
people with asperger's and with
cognitive disabilities usually
they work in a very functional way so if
they arrive at your website
they don't really do browsing or surfing
but they have very strictly defined
expectations
and they're looking for very specific
information
so a search box is usually the best
the best thing you can you can you can
do to cater for that then again
visible context is absolutely essential
and the breadcrumb trail is a great
example of that
so i like to know where i am
in the structure of your site or your
app and
how i got there and how i got to any
particular point and
where i can move forwards and backwards
so that's
that's always for the best
another thing is that whenever you have
any long chunk of text
probably the worst thing that you can do
is to break it up into sections
so that first you display the first 25
of an article and then you have to click
next or number two to display the next
25
etc etc
um
like i said we we usually have a have an
eye for
for a quick overview
and
this really grounds us and allows some
sense of control over what's going on
so
whenever possible you might want to
really put the entire text there
if possible that really might help
um
when it comes to navigation um this can
also be quite tricky
um
for instance if you have any
navigational elements on the left hand
side of your website and then some other
navigational elements at the top and
then some additional menus at the right
and then some links at the bottom
um
we can be baffled at how all of these
navigational elements relate to one
another we might want to make some sort
of sense of
why
some items are on the left and why those
are on the top and if there's any
logical connection between them and so
we can get really stuck thinking about
that
so if
if at all possible you might want to
group all navigation
in one place that really makes things
easier
then there's language and i really can't
stress enough that
good copywriting is also
good accessibility
so
first of all try and use language
that's direct and literal
due to issues with
uh immediately understanding irony and
metaphor and idioms
for example in this text here
reads
yesterday in a nutshell first it was
raining cats and dogs then got canned
etc so when i'm reading this text
my first impression is very visual
and i see i really do see a nutshell and
then i see cats and dogs raining from
the sky and then i see joe being in a
can with its top off
and it really takes
some extra milliseconds or seconds of
that
computational power of the brain for me
to actually
arrive at a conclusion oh yeah so this
is an idiom and it means this and that
okay let's get to the next one so
this can really be an obstacle and so
you really might want to
think of that whenever you catch
yourself using some catchphrases or
idiomatic expressions especially when
they're spiked with
visual vocabulary
another way to make language easier is
to use very clear titles and summaries
other than a very quick overview which
we obviously cherish
it also provides context
so this is a fairly known
valuer known technique in journalism
this is called inverted pyramid writing
and it's often found in newspaper
articles you have a headline then you
have a quick summary and then you just
get to the article itself
so you also might want to think about
that
um
oh and i love this one uh yes list and
indices whenever possible whenever you
see the opportunity
uh try and itemize or list things
because
people would ask because we just love
lists we love lists of lists and lists
of how to organize lists and how to
organize lists of lists of lists and i
could go on and on so i'm just crazy
about organizing so just remember that
list
lists are made of absolute win for us
and that's really for the best
then
then
going further
whenever you have any sort of hyperlinks
or buttons
that say click me or click here
the first impression for users with
cognitive
issues
is
being an alice in wonderland and
just seeing all these imperatives
everywhere telling them to click here or
click there eat me drink me this is this
is absolutely terrible
what you might want to do is make the
links
really self-explanatory really telling
the user where they lead
and what's
what's behind the door
so instead of click me or click here for
more info
a better way to do this would be say
details of our return policy of go to
home page etc
so i'm careful with that now
when it comes to design itself
um obviously
high arousal websites are a horror to
look at
so this is an example of something that
you don't want to do
so
no flickering no super bright colors no
animations movements sounds um also be
fairly careful with contrast
um
you really might want to
use relatively high contrast but not too
high
so this is a very fine line so so
careful with that because
uh
because some some users might find
too high or too low contrast quite
daunting
so just
basically you don't want to do any
old-school late 90s design
um like geocities or angel fire um i
don't know how many of you here remember
geocities raise your hand
oh yes thank god
yeah so so you might remember this uh
all those animated uh gifs of
like flames or revolving skulls or
horizontal lines with like blood and
animated rainbows and marquis
god that was so terrible that was such a
dark age
of the internet
and and then came flash or the horror of
flash
so
so i'm really grateful that we are where
we are right now um
and then understandably uh try and avoid
patterns
uh because um
we might either get overwhelmed
by the patterns
or shut down so either stuck or
fascinated and you don't really want the
user to react in any of those two
extremes
um
branding is an interesting one which is
often overlooked
you should be very very careful whenever
you're designing a logo or putting any
sort of branding on your site or on your
product or in your app
because branding is very often
metaphorical
in a way that's
not immediately understood or direct
an example of this is the nike logo
this is a sports company
and i'm really baffled at what what it
means and what's the relation of this
sushi thing to
a sports company or tonight itself
it makes absolutely no sense so
this might really be confusing for your
cognitively challenged user
um a good example of
direct branding uh is the shell logo i
mean it's a shell a company's called
shell i get that that's cool i'm cool
with that
there's
going forward there's another
interesting thing
whenever you have a chunk of text
try not to justify it
to left and to right at the same time so
that it's justified on both sides an
example of that is on the left
we can really uh
get confused and stuck on what's called
the rivers of white so these are the
white spaces that are created by the
justification
to uh to adapt to the new line length
so reading such text is
can be immensely difficult and we can
get stuck because
all the white space sort of emerges from
the text and may create some
some imagery or some lines
so if i look at this i see um
on the left i see a tree that's
reflected in a lake and on the right
a dog barking up the tree and some
clouds on top so it roughly looks like
this
so
as you can guess this is
this is fairly difficult to read because
you know uh you know i i i get stuck but
by all the images i see there so um so
the example on the right is absolutely
perfect because the rivulets don't
really form anything
so try and use just left hand
justification if whenever you can
speed control
is something that you should always try
to allow
whenever you have any sort of
uh image reel or a slight show
you really don't want to impose your own
speed up on the user
you really want to let them slow
everything down and just read everything
at their own pace or maybe speed it up
so
any way to do that
is
just to provide some sort of navigation
through the slideshow or through the
elements
or if you have a video you might want to
provide an option to slow it down or
speed it up
interaction
this is immensely important
first of all
for the record i'd like to state that
online chat is absolute win when it
comes to
social interactions
for ass piece because talking online is
really easy
there are no mystifying mystifying
facial expressions
uh we just read the smileys and the lols
and we type them back and that's all
there is to it i mean it's obvious to us
so interaction is finally made easy
because i don't have to read all the
strange facial twitches in your body
language um
plus
i would even go as far as saying that
online dating must have been invented by
someone with asperger's because actually
online we can appear to be half smart
which is cool
so that and text messages should really
be made an official language
you might also be want to be very
careful when it comes to
forms or any sort of input
in your app
this is an example of a badly designed
form
for someone with cognitive impairments
have
seen
this form being filled out by a user
with aspergers
who put
their first home address in the first
line
then the alternative address in the
second line and then
their mother's home address in the third
line because they thought that three
alternatives were being asked of them so
what you should what you should do
instead is address line one
street name address line to
street name continued and whatnot you
know you just have to try and make it as
specific as you can
um
also whenever you have
an infant box that
in which uh you put any sort of logic
such as and or
or some as in name your five biggest and
most successful achievements
uh we can get really stuck on this
because uh i'll be thinking that well
do you want five of my biggest
achievements
and five of my most successful ones or
some of those uh and maybe two of my
biggest ones and three of my most
successful ones because you know
logically um
you have to be thinking as as if you
were
giving this sort of command to a
computer
as for example when you're writing a
program you have to make sure that your
logic is absolutely impeccable
and imagine that you're asking computers
to return a value for you you just
you just
wouldn't want to
make anything fuzzy and
and doubtful there and also make sure
that you use very clear feedback
feedback whenever possible
um okay um
furthermore um
we really like to control our
surroundings to maybe cope with anxiety
or
apply some
strict wacky habits of our own or our
personal roles to the world
so
i i know this is fairly rare
because i don't see that very often but
when you give a control
over presentation such as choosing a
color theme or adjusting the saturation
that really makes things easier
oh and also
try and not impose your own font size
from the user just
um allow them to resize it in the
browser that's that's always
uh
that always wins our hearts too
um
having said that
you really might want to
think of users with asperger's
as your ultimate ideal perfect testers
for your apps and for your products in
terms of
usability and accessibility
first of all
we're brutally honest especially when
asked a very direct question where less
prone to lying
we loved correct
we're really obsessed about
detail and controlling everything
and
we're also like super sensitive and
we exaggerate and overreact over partic
over everything really so what bothers
a normal
uh person really bothers a person with
asperger's like a hundred times more
so
you've got a very very sensitive
and very fine-tuned instrument of a
tester there possibly
the takeaway from all of this is that
accessibility for users with cognitive
impairments
translates itself directly to
just general usability for everyone
and
much of what i've said might appear
obvious but
once you really grasp
these really basic guidelines you really
might arrive at a very usable and very
accessible product for absolutely
everyone
so you really want to think about
accessibility
for cognitive impairments at every
single stage
during development during design
so
like i said whether you're a developer
or a designer
this is what you should be thinking
about and
that is what i wanted to say and let me
just add one more thing um looking back
at the history of
web design and development and app app
development
i
do think that we're on the right path
because years ago everything was very
much inaccessible
and
now the web is just beautiful and apps
are beautiful and it fills me with like
with childlike wonder
because there are very clear visual cues
everything is
minimalistic everything is simple and
while these things might appear quite
natural
and obvious you guys
as designers and developers are really
life savers and
uh
you really do make the web a friendly
place and it all proves that the
very existence of the ui and ux movement
um
is really doing a great job
so yes thank you so much you can follow
me on twitter at battalion thank you for
having me
you